パシャパシャ【カメラのシャッター音】
(記者)：それでは
(記者)：記者会見を始めさせていただきます
(記者)：はじめさん
はじめ：はい
(記者)：なぜここにいるのかわかっているんですか？
はじめ：えー先日
私のメインチャンネルで
あげさせていただいた動画の一部の中に
はじめ：えー
はじめ：トークというかその
お話する
欄がありまして、
そのトークの中に
その女性の名前が…
あのモザイクかけたんですけども、
一瞬
ちょっと編集の…こちらのミスで
見えてしまっておりまして、
えーそのー
女性の名前が写っていたせいで、
一部の視聴者様
そして
関係者の皆様に御迷惑
をおかけしてしまい、
そして
えーお騒がせしてしまったことです。
(記者)：まずは謝罪でしょ！
はじめ：スー
はじめ：あのホントに
視聴様の皆様には、
大変なご心配、そして
えー
お騒がせしてしまい本当に申し訳ございませんでした。
(記者)：今回の騒動について、どうお考えですか？
はじめ：はい
えー
はじめ：実際動画に写り込んでいた女性
の名前は、
“まなみ”という女性のものに
なるんですけども、
実際にチャットはしていなくても、
1回触っちゃうとトークが、この出来ちゃって、
なので、実際にその…
まなみさんという方とはお話しもしていなくて、
あの画面上に表示された、まなみさんという方は、
えっと、僕が誤って
まなみさんという
ユーザーをタッチしてしまって、
上に出てきてしまったという
トークなんでありまして、
実際にアプリ内での会話は…なく、
ネット上ではですね、その…
彼女だという噂がかなりたてられておりますが
そのような事実は一切ございません。
はじめ：まぁ実際にあの場で
チャットをした、お話をしたという事実もございません
(記者)：まなみさんとの関係性について教えてもらっていいですか？
はじめ：はい。“友達かも？”みたいなその欄がありまして
そこで、たまたまあの方がいて、
僕がたまたま押してしまって、押した結果、
その、トークの画面が出てきちゃって、上の方に上がっちゃって、
最近まなみさんと、お話したような映り方をしてしまったのではないかなと思っております。
(記者 )一部の人たちの中では、まなみさんの正体を突き止めようとしていますが
それについてはいかがでしょうか？
はじめ：はい
え～
はじめ：正直な話をしますと、
あの～
はじめ：一瞬、女性の名前が映り込んだだけで、
あんな風にその、“彼女ができた”とか
“まなみって人は彼女なの？”みたいな
決めつけですね。
はじめ：事実とは異なる内容を
信じ込んでしまい、それを勝手に拡散されたりすることは非常に
迷惑な行為だと
わたくしは感じております。
(記者)：ファンの方々に一言
はじめ：はい
え～
はじめ：ほんの一部の方なんですけども、
実際にその、まなみさんという方と付き合ってるみたいな話を信じてしまった方も
大勢いらっしゃいましたが、
あの～
ネットっていうのは、
いろんな情報が飛び交っていて、
とてもおもしろい、場ではあると思うのですが、
事実と異なることが非常に多くもあります。
まぁその点において、
はじめ：ｺﾝｺｲ
まさき：ﾌﾝｯﾌﾌﾌｯ
まさき：ごめん。今日一番面白かった
はじめ：今回のような
え～
はじめ：根も葉もない噂。名前が映ってしまっただけで
“彼女じゃないの？”みたいな、そういった憶測で物事を判断してしまうことは
非常によろしくないことだと、わたくしは思っております。
はじめ：ネットの情報は非常に
正しいものか正しくないのかの判断が、
難しいものが多いので、
そこらへんはしっかり、見分ける能力を
まぁ大切にしていってもらいたいなと、わたくしは思っております。
(記者)：はじめさんの好きなアイドル、前島亜美さんが卒業することについて
どうお考えですか？
はじめ：ｸｯｯｽﾝ
はじめ：非常に悲しく思っております
(記者)：まなみさんについてですが
正体が(ﾋﾟｰ)まなみ、とネットで挙がっているのですが
それについてはどうなんですか？
はじめ：違うって言ってんだろうぉぉぉぉ！！
勝手になぁぁ
お前、勝手に
はじめ：でも事実と異なるんです。
はじめ：そういうとこが嫌なんだよぉ。
(記者)：ではネットの情報はデマということですかね
はじめ：はい
はじめ：その件に関しましては
えー、わたくしの
心からの
NOでございます。
(記者)：ファンの中では
(記者)：付き合っていて辛いと、言うファンの声もあるんですが、
そのファンの方々に向けて一言、頂きたいと思います。
えっ？耳が遠くて聞こえないんですけど
(記者)：あのっ、付き合ってる説が辛いってなってるんですけど
どう思いますかって
はじめ：こっちが辛いよぉぉぉぉぉ！！！！！
こっちが辛いよぉぉぉ！
はじめ：まなみちゃんと……付き合いたいよwww
はじめ：それは違うか
はじめ：あの～
はじめ：本当に、ちゃんと僕がその
まなみさんという人と
ツーショットとか
付き合ってるような、あれだったら
まぁ、そうかもしれませんよ。
ただ、
ﾝｧｯ
はじめ：名前が出ただけでしょう
はじめ：名前が出ただけで彼女だったら、もう何しても彼女じゃないですか
ｶｯｶｯ
はじめ：だからそういうことでしょう、だって。あなたたちが言いたいことは
はじめ：そうでしょう？
はじめ：何しても彼女なんでしょ？
じゃあ何。腕に
ｼﾞｬｯ
はじめ：あっ。みなみって書いてあったら、みなみちゃんじゃないか彼女
おかしいでしょ
全部彼女になっちゃうじゃん、そんなことしたら
はじめ：アプリで女の子の名前でたら彼女って、どうなってんの
もぉぉぉ、お前やることやってんだろう！！
(記者)：落ち着いてください
はじめ：はい
はじめ：すみません。取り乱しました
(記者)：Twitterが相互フォローの関係になっているといのが発端で
こうなっているのですが
それについてはどう思うんですか？
はじめ：その件に関しましては、
えー、以前
お仕事で一度、ご一緒させていただいたことがありまして、
その件でフォローさせていただいたのですが、
そのお仕事の件以外では、
一切連絡を取ったこともなく、会ったことも一切ございません
(記者)：ファンのツイートで、
(記者)：もし付き合っていたら全力で応援したい、どちらも大好きだからという声があるんですが
いかがでしょうか
はじめ：付き合ってねぇって言ってんだろうぉぉぉ！！！
はじめ：応援はありがたいよ、応援はありがたいけど
そういう思い込みがだm
(記者)：相互フォローとLINEも繋がっているらしいという説があるんですが
LINEの方はどうなんですか
はじめ：繋がってない！！
(記者)：まさきさんは相互フォローの関係にあるんですか
まさき：いえ、私はそのフォローには関係ありません
(記者)：ということは、ネットにあった
(記者)：まなみさんと付き合っているという件について
それは嘘ということですね。
はじめ：はい。
はじめ：事実としましては、
一切
まなみさんという女性とは
関係がございません
全て
ネットの勝手な憶測、
噂、
そういうもので
作られた
虚言でございます。
(記者)：それでは、まさきさん。
一言お願いします
まさき：今回の件は、本当にはじめさんのおっしゃっている通りだと思います。
(記者)：まさきさん行きたいところを、教えてください
江の島ですかね
はじめ：ちょっとギリギリじゃねwww